you've been canceled even here did that
bother you I know that the AG I'm with
your agent I'm with I'm with your old
agent I'm with WME oh you are yes yeah
well they wish they were my new agent
too now they've been chomping at the bit
hey Tony you know we'd love to you know
that wasn't that came from above that
wasn't us we loved really are they
coming back they they wish well now I'm
with the head of UTA literally their
worst nightmare so it's fun I know so
for those that don't know you got in
some to some controversy the agency just
SE well they created their own news
cycle is what they did unfortunately you
know the story was dying out I made fun
of an Asian comedian during an actual
standup comedy show where recording
wasn't allowed and uh it was taken out
of context and the comedian tried to get
famous off of that it was uh it was
Asian Heritage Month and you weren't
allowed to make fun of Asians and at the
time the media was saying that Asians
were being attacked uh by people this
was you know Co um towards the end of Co
um and the storyline from the media is
that they were being blamed for this
from crazy people so anyway I do jokes
as I do and um you know when it's Asian
Heritage Month and they're under uh the
spotlight in the News That's when I do
go for it right right now I'm doing
Israel and Palestine jokes that yes if a
lot of people saw them they would clip
it and put it on the internet and go can
you believe what this guy's saying but
if you're not a comedy fan and you're
not in the room specifically and you
didn't see what happened before that of
course of course things can be taken out
but I always say okay go ahead we W me
but oh yeah and um so yeah so when that
happened um you know it was a giant
giant news story which is absolutely
crazy to me that anything that happens
at a cement Comedy Club the temporary
holding tank that was the Vulcan gas
company I mean a dinky little and
there's not even like separate operators
between the bathroom stalls or anything
like it was just a it was literally a
[__] show and uh um you know this was
the news and
WME uh dropped me and it was their own
news story you know they pay it was a
virtue signaling time in history for a
lot of big companies and things and I
don't think it's quite like that and
right now I've seen the temperature kind
of change but right then it was the
extreme
virtue did did you panic oh it was a
horrendous three days it was it was very
bizarre I could see how it could turn
out great but you still are like wait
what it was then that really you know I
leaned all the way into the freedom of
Texas because it's like even though it
happened here which is crazy because I
was doing crazy jokes in La for 16 years
before moving here um the city embraced
me and like when I went up four or five
days after that incident for the first
time ever the boom was crazier than ever
and I'm like oh okay I just don't think
you can get canceled for a joke and
trust me WME wishes they didn't do
that